Film Courage:What advice do you have for
a screenwriter when they sit down to start
writing a screenplay?What are some things
they should have already done before before
they type that first page? Whether it’s outlining, etc.?
CSUN’s Eric Edson: They should have beside them a list of the
100 most-recent screenplays that they have
read. The published ones, the successful ones...Okay!...I’ll
give you a break...make it 50.
You are not ready to write until you are very
well-read and well-versed in the literature
you are proposing to create. And in this case,
it’s screenwriting.
I would say systematize your organization.
The first thing you have to do...see a really
bad habit that most screenwriters have is
that they’ve got a great idea and they’re
cooking and they just start writing a screenplay
“I’m writing screenplay pages. Oh boy!”
And it’s fun but it’s going nowhere ultimately
without a plan and a very well thought out
one. The hard work is in the outline and it
has to be a very complete outline and you
have to have confidence that all story problems
have been addressed.
So the first thing you have to do is the dirty
work, the outline. Write yourself...I would
say hero-goal sequences because I happen to
think and I happen to know that it works.
But however you know, beat sheet, (however
they do it), have a very complete outline.
And then good bloody luck.
It’s a lot of work and then I would also
say...yeah, you can write it on a little piece
of paper and tape it above your desk, “Write
Badly With Pride.” No writer’s block.
None. Just write badly with pride. Write a
piece of junk.
You know, if you haven’t, just sitting there
staring at the wall for an hour, okay. What
would you write if you were just really writing
trash, really writing garbage? Go for it.
Because you’ll never know when the real
idea is the depth of what you are doing will
be sparked. You just don’t know. You don’t
know and there’s so many things you have,
the tone.
I’m working on and beginning to have some
fun at this stage of things. I have some original
screenplays (of course) as it turns out, that
never sold. And frequently what happens is
the stuff you like the most, that’s the
stuff that doesn’t sell. And there are three
or four of them that I want to turn into novels
before my clock and race have been run. And
I started on one some months back. And I’ve
been working a month and a half now on the
first five pages.
Every day I do...I kind of fell into it, but
it’s what Ernest Hemingway did. Everyday
he started at page one and that’s what I
have to do by instruction of being instructed
by him but also by a nature, every day I start
at page one. You can do that for the first
40 or 50 pages you reach a point, you know
it doesn’t work anymore but what you do
by that, what you gain by that is do not be
in a hurry to zoom onward. Because those first
five to ten pages are the most important pages
in the whole thing, in a novel, in a screenplay.
You either convince your audience it’s worth
to come along (or reader), it’s worth their
time to come along for this journey with you
or not. Either they trust you by then or they
don’t.
So in the search for the tone, rhythm, the
use of language and character, it’s amazing
spending five pages with your central character
in this case. What you can learn about that
character and doing the same five pages over
and over and over and over. You’ll learn
a heck of a lot about your hero. This is invaluable
as you move forward. So I would say also,
don’t rush.